in Hamburg they're bringing out the Dead
people shot where they worshiped
victims of a man in the shadows this
figure by a window
the hail of bullets shows he had no
mercy
an unborn baby among those gunned down
inside a Jehovah's Witness Center
um
I'm a resident up here and I heard loud
gunshots so I went to the window to get
an idea of the situation then I saw that
a man was shooting out of the window
with a firearm there were people being
carried out and there were probably 25
shots at least that I heard
shots were reported here around 9pm
police arrived in a matter of minutes
interrupting and horrific attack seven
dead including the seven-month-old
unborn child whose mother survived
shellshock neighbors say officers search
for accomplices before confirming the
lone gunman had shot himself
we got a message from the police that we
shouldn't leave the house and three
policemen came and searched all the
houses here they were probably looking
for a fugitive but afterwards they found
the one who is now dead
the man responsible named as Philip F
also once worshiped here before he left
police say the sports shooter fired more
than a hundred rounds of ammunition at
his former group
is
through the window the shooter shot into
the building got into the building
through the window and continued to
shoot
police said that the gunman was
previously investigated after they
received an anonymous tip that he may
not be suitable to Bear Firearms but
when they visited him they found he
hadn't broken any rules and at that
point legally they said they couldn't
take it any further
some will question if this could have
been prevented but for now this city
Mourns
still reeling from one of the worst
crimes in its recent history Siobhan
Robbins Sky News Hamburg